in the break a general you mentioned
that you feel that the public vastly
misunderstands how much information the
government has and can track so what can
the NSA in the government see in terms
of my phone calls my email
communications my text messages what
does the government know about me about
you other than on Bloomberg that you're
a great that you're great journalists
and great TV personality if you're
talking to a terrorist than NSA or other
government agencies would have a reason
to do it but under FISA the government
would require a warrant to track your
communications period for NSA NSA's
responsibilities are foreign so think of
the zazie case which is out there public
this was the guy who was going to blow
up the new york city subway without his
med is unit so what NSA had to do under
the 702 program was get a court order to
allow them which was the 702 to get
information on the communications going
from and al-qaeda known terrorists with
Ozzy that's what NSA in that program is
geared towards NSA is the foreign side
of this not the domestic and so this
perception that under the metadata
program we're listening to your phone
calls or reading your emails is
completely false unless you're talking
to a terrorist who's overseas domestic
it would be the same thing with the FBI
they have to have a warrant or some
reason probable cause under FISA
actually or under Title 3 warrant to go
after but what about the dragnet so the
dragnet this is the 215 program the
metadata program let's go over what's in
this is information that you collect
right well this is actually business
records that the government compels the
Internet service providers to provide
which has only numbers in it no content
it has the to and from number the
date-time group of the call in the
duration of the call only those four
things your names out in there no
content is in there I'll repeat no names
no content just numbers what that's used
for is let's say
DK's there was actually a number in that
zazie communication FBI told NSA that
was Ozzy's number and we now know he's
talking to al-qaeda under the rules at
the time NSA had have proof to look in
the database that it was associated that
that number was associated with al-qaeda
then one of 35 people could look into
that database and go out three hops to
see who he was talking to and going out
three hops they were able to see that
one of the people in New York had
downstream connections to other
terrorists and all they saw was the
numbers and then the numbers resulted in
somebody overseas who is known to be
terrace NSA would then give that number
of New York City not knowing who it was
two FBI FBI with a national security
letter could look that up so you see
NSA's job was to connect the dots from
9-11 not to listen to your
communications or others so one of the
things that's really wrong is all that
about content